hablamos del par y gay del escándalo por
las fiestas del gobierno de boris
johnson durante el confinamiento en
reino unido hasta el momento se han
documentado más de cinco reuniones en
down street durante los peores momentos
de las restricciones para evitar la
propagación del hobbit 19 tras revelarse
este escándalo que causa indicación en
el país la semana pasada el gobierno
pidió una serie de disculpas una de
ellas dirigida a la reina isabel y
segunda ya que una de la fiesta se dio
en pleno duelo nacional por la muerte
del duque de edimburgo sin embargo para
muchos las disculpas llegaron demasiado
tarde y ahora suenan los pedidos para la
renuncia de boris johnson saludó
entonces a paulina astros a ella
directora del programa de estudios
europeos de la universidad de concepción
en chile gracias paulina por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
la pregunta del millón podrá entonces el
primer ministro superar este escándalo y
continuar en el poder
hola como estan mira es bastante
complicada la situación que está no es
cierto que boris johnson ha tenido
varias crisis varios escándalos pero el
de ahora se le está complicando
muchísimo más pero para llegar a esa
supuesta destitución o cambio de
gobierno la verdad es que todavía faltan
algunos pasos pero yo creo que es el
momento toda en el cual ha estado más
cerca de la dimisión por las presiones
que tiene tanto dentro de su propio
partido como también por la ciudadanía
ahora paulina son suficientes estas
disculpas desde todo su gobierno incluso
las disculpas a la reina isabel segunda
que quiere la población exactamente que
necesitaría para poder car para poder
calmar estos ánimos
mira hay distintas formas en las cuales
él podría reaccionar una dimitiera
voluntariamente cosa que no cree es
porque ya se sabe que su entorno más
cercano está con una estrategia que se
llama save the beat box dog en el fondo
salvar al gran perro y que ha comenzado
con el anuncio de distintas medidas
bastante demagógica para que contentar a
la población esa es su primera
estrategia ya ha anunciado por ejemplo
el hecho que va
a va a
limitar o a congelar los fondos que se
le da a la bbc y que se van a terminar
con esta subvención para el año 2027
entre otras medidas medidas también
relativas a restricciones sanitarias
adhiera los pocos y en fin una serie de
anuncios que está haciendo esta semana
para lograr contentar un poco a esta
población que está indignada que las
encuestas están señalando incluso un 66
por ciento indica 155 indica otras están
de acuerdo en que el dimita porque se
sienten engañados y más aún que se hayan
hecho fiestas no solamente antes del
funeral de el príncipe felipe sino que
además en condiciones las cuales el
resto de la población no podían salir no
los bares están cerrados no podían ellos
mismos acudir a funerales
porque estaban con estas restricciones y
sin embargo en tan distritos se daban el
lujo de tener estas fiestas en alguna de
las cuales habría participado de origen
son y es que de esa fiesta de la que
usted habla fue precisamente el en mayo
de 2020 recién empezaba el confinamiento
recién casi empezado lo fuerte de esta
primera ola de la pandemia de kobe 19
pero paulino le pregunto si realmente en
downey street andamio suite fueron
fiestas recordemos que el primer
ministro boris johnson en el parlamento
dijo pensé que era una reunión de
trabajo
simplemente acudí 25 minutos pero
realmente fueron fiestas además qué pasa
con este famoso correo donde le decían a
los invitados traigan su propia bebida
en una frase ahora también muy sonada en
el reino unido en torno a toda esta
polémica de las fiestas que sucedieron
en pleno confinamiento de la pandemia de
kobe 19 de paulina mira eso está bajo
investigación de la vicepresienta
permanente sucre y actualmente que tiene
que emitir un informe si realmente hubo
o no hubo fiestas pero dado toda la
información que está saliendo y el mismo
hecho que boris johnson le haya pedido
disculpas en la cámara de comunes
aparece claro que éstas existieron
porque no solamente esta actividad el 20
de mayo a la cual tú señalas en el cual
se envía un correo del asesor directo de
boris johnson a cerca de 100 personas
diciéndole qué bueno que aprovecharan el
buen tiempo y de celebrar con como tú
dices llevando cada uno su propio su
propia botella que pasó a ser un hashtag
además en twitter sino que además se
sabe ahora que dentro de downstream a
guía los días viernes se llamaba el
viernes del vino en el cual también se
llevaba licor y donde también los días
viernes como a modo de relajo
se reunían un grupo de personas cuando
el resto de la población británica no
podía hacer lo mismo entonces se están
sumando una serie de situaciones que por
mucho que él diga que pensaba que era
una reunión de trabajo donde incluso con
la que en ese momento ni siquiera era
todavía su señora aparece con licor y
tomando la verdad que hace muy poco
creíble lo que está señalando el más aún
cuando el semanario del espectador
en el cual durante seis años por y
johnson lo dirigió hoy día se sabe que
justamente cuando él termina de ser el
director de este diario
en la forma en que ocurrían las cosas en
ese diario era como lo que está
ocurriendo ahora o sea mucho alcohol y
mucha cuerda y eso también complica la
imagen y la reputación del primer
ministro
se habla también
paulina y sobre todo en el parlamento
del comité 1922 porque es clave ahora
este comité y también explíquenos
entonces en qué consiste
a ver este comité se llama así porque en
1922 fue que se formó pese que empieza a
operar en 1923
está integrado por aquellos
parlamentarios conservadores que no
tienen puestos en el gobierno y se junta
en el 15 por ciento de ese número de
parlamentarios que hoy día
corresponderían a 54 si es que se juntan
54 cartas de diputados que no tienen un
asiento en el gobierno y son
conservadores y piden que se active lo
que se llama una moción de retirada de
confianza esto automáticamente
implicaría una votación en el parlamento
para para la destitución del primer
ministro esto no significa que con la
destitución del primer ministro cae el
gobierno sino que significa que el
partido conservador debería nombrar a un
nuevo a un nuevo líder conservador
ese procedimiento de las cartas es
secreto pero según algunas informaciones
ya tendrían al menos unas 35 cartas de
estos parlamentarios que con no
funciones en el gobierno que ya habrían
mandado esas cartas por lo tanto sí es
cierto tal vez con toda esta información
que está saliendo ahora logren tener las
54 cartas y con eso se activa
automáticamente el proceso de la moción
de retiro la confianza en el congreso en
el parlamento la cámara de los comunes y
eso ya está fuera de control de boris
johnson por lo tanto ya no deben de él
sino que depende del partido conservador
muy rápido paulista nos quedan ya 35
segundos para terminar esta conversación
y viendo desde su experiencia no cuál
puede ser el futuro cercano de boris
johnson si se mantiene o no se va
yo creo que le quedan días
ya sea por una presión exterior de
digamos de los ciudadanos que están muy
enfadados o están aumentando mucho la
los laboristas en la encuesta o sea
porque logré estas 54 cartas y sea su
propio partido quien o lo destituye
había parlamento o la presión sea tan
grande el interior que el término
termine dimitiendo paulina pues gracias
por su análisis por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 ha sido
un gusto conversar con usted el día de
hoy